let's think about calculating torque I
have a force F being applied to an
object and that object is pivoted at a
point Q I'll define R as the vector from
the pivot point Q to the point of the
application of the force torque is
defined as the cross product R cross F
which we can also write as R times F
times the sine of theta but what does
that mean
I'll introduce two different intuitive
ways of understanding this mathematical
expression first we can think about this
as the magnitude of F times the quantity
R sine theta if we look at the direction
of the force then it is easy to see that
R sine theta is just the part of R that
is perpendicular to the force so here
the torque is equal to the magnitude of
the force times the magnitude of this
perpendicular part of the vector R this
perpendicular portion of the distance
vector R is often referred to as the
moment arm we can instead group F with
sine theta so this means that we're
thinking of the cross-product as the
distance R multiplied by F sine theta
the component of the force F that's
perpendicular to the position vector R
here I'm calculating torque as the
distance between the pivot point and
where the force is applied times the
perpendicular part of the force be very
careful about the sine theta term in
many cases the angle theta that is given
in the problem is not the angle that is
used in the expression in this example f
times the sine of theta will actually
give the parallel component of the force
therefore it is much better to remember
to take the perpendicular component
rather than just memorizing sine of
theta